[Music]
this is almost surreal to say but the
channel recently passed 1 million
subscribers and I know what you're
thinking just 48 thousand five hundred
seventy-six more to go before the next
big milestone and indeed I'll hold off
proper celebrations until then but you
know seeing that seventh digit really
does make you reflect on what led to
this point and if I'm being honest a lot
of the growth for this channel just had
to do with some very kind people sharing
and promoting the content both in terms
of certain specific shoutouts from
creators with big audiences and in terms
of individuals just sharing with their
friends so what I want to do now is take
a moment to let you all know about a few
other math creators online who I think
you would like a lot there's just so
much good creation that happens under a
lot of people's radars first up we have
the channel think twice I honestly have
no idea why this channel isn't better
known among online math communities it
contains these really beautifully done
math animations and if you like this
channel you're definitely gonna like it
you absolutely get the sense looking at
any one of these that it comes from
someone who thinks very visually about
math naturally this often takes the form
in some very pretty geometry or some
algebraic results that are explained
geometrically and the focus tends to be
a little bit more short form and
bite-sized pieces so if you ever want a
quick little reminder of why math is
beautiful this is just a great channel
to pop over to here let me justlet a
couple more of these animations just
play out
[Music]
next up I'd recommend you check out leoz
OS run by James schloss what I like
about James is that he seems to think
first and foremost about community and
creating content seems to be more of a
vehicle for bringing people together
online let me turn things over to him to
explain what it's all about
both on and off youtube Leo's OS is
fundamentally a channel about algorithms
and works with the arcane algorithm
archive an open source and collaborative
effort to document every algorithm in
existence in every language possible
we're just getting started and it's
obviously an impossible goal but that's
half the fun this means that we cover a
range of different topics and here are
some clips of the videos any light that
enters a lens leaves on the other side
of the lens with the same angle it came
in with it's almost as if the light
never entered the lens at all and hence
the name the invisible lens if we take
any arbitrary matrix say the identity
matrix with zeros along the W dimension
the rotation doesn't look quite right
this is because most tesseract
depictions use stereographic projections
which resemble the act of holding a
light source behind an object and
checking a shadow against the screen
here we divide our points into smaller
packages and use the grande scan to find
their convex holes we then take the
vertices from the holes and plug them
into the jarvis March to create a
wrapped gift of wrapped gifts this is of
course just a small subset of the types
of videos on our channel quickly I would
like to thank grant for making such
amazing videos on three blue and brown
it's inspiring to see such a large and
dedicated community attempting to
understand the true beauty of
mathematics you guys are honestly
amazing so even if I don't see you guys
again
please keep being such an awesome
community for my part I think it would
be awesome to see this algorithms
archive grow more both of the last two
at least on YouTube have shorter form
content so next let's switch to a
channel with more of a long-form folk
Welsh Labs run by Stephen Welsh now I
suspect many of you already know about
Stephens work for example the excellent
series imaginary numbers are real but
there are many other great playlists
from the channel that you should
absolutely take a look at in fact one of
the things I like most about this
channel is that Stephen think in terms
of series rather than in terms of
individual videos and each one of them
includes clear points where the viewer
can engage with the materials more than
just through a passive viewing
experience often including workbooks and
associated PDFs so the focus really is
on learning more so than just
entertainment to get a feel here let me
just play some snippets from the start
and then from the end of his imaginary
numbers are real series which should
give you a pretty good feel for the
style in the scope and I'll also throw
in a snippet from his series on machine
learning algebraically this new
dimension has everything to do with a
problem that was considered impossible
for over 2,000 years
the square root of negative one when we
include this missing dimension in our
analysis our parabola gets way more
interesting now that our input numbers
are in their full two dimensional form
we can see how our function x squared
plus 1 really behaves our function does
cross the x-axis we were just looking in
the wrong dimension so why is this extra
dimension that numbers possessed not
common knowledge part of the reason is
that it has been given a terrible
terrible name a name that suggests that
these numbers aren't even real all right
and ready will draw the same exact paths
on w and see how they show up on our
remind surface as they are mapped to our
z plane
[Music]
so why does our green path start out at
one location on our Z plane only to end
up in another simply because our green
path leads us to the other layer of our
service from the perspective of our W
plane it appears that we've returned
exactly to our starting point but
actually we have it the W plane is just
a projection a shadow in reality our
path has led us to a completely
different branch of our function this is
a decision tree right now it's learning
when it's done it'll have learned to do
something very human something that
everyone knows how to do but no one can
quite explain how they do it something
that is fooled generations of brilliant
scientists with its apparent simplicity
but practical complexity something that
has only become possible in the last few
decades thanks to creative solutions in
the face of huge complexity it's
learning to see let's test it out with
the help of a camera and a computer our
decision tree sees exactly how many
fingers were holding up now depending on
who you are the fact that a machine can
perform this task may be completely
mind-blowing not all that out of the
ordinary or may not even be all that
impressive the good news here is
whichever camp you're in you're in good
company our finger counting machine is a
simple example that belongs to a
deceptively complex class of problem
problems that arise from thinking about
how we think and finally turning away
from the YouTube world I want to
highlight the blog infinity plus one the
tone of the writing and the associated
visuals are both delightfully playful
but the author James Dilts manages to
get in some pretty substantive math all
while keeping it accessible a
particularly good sequence of posts is
the one he did on relativity
both special and general and it's a
little hard to directly feature text
posts and video forms but I'll leave you
some links in the description to some of
my favorite posts and of course the
description also has links for the other
three creators mentioned here
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]